-Welcome back, everybody.
The NFL season kicked off
last Thursday night
with a game between
the Kansas City Chiefs
and the Houston Texans.
And while it was great
to see football again,
there was a moment that left
many people confused
when fans started booing during
a pregame moment of unity --
protest against racism.
After the incident, one of
the players shared his thoughts.
[ Indistinct conversations ]
-People seem to be confused
about why we did what we did.
We feel as though,
with everything that's going on
in the world today,
we couldn't help
but to take a stand.
We may be athletes,
but at the end of the day,
we're all human beings.
It was clearly
the right thing to do,
to take a knee against racism.
[ Crowd boos ]
But -- But...we also realize
that taking a stance like that
might have made some people
uncomfortable,
so instead of taking a knee,
from now on,
we will be wearing
"Black Lives Matter" T-shirts.
[ Crowd boos ]
Uh, okay. Um.
That's a no go on the T-shirts.
Okay, okay.
Instead of a T-shirt,
we'll be wearing
"Black Lives Matter" bracelets.
[ Crowd booing ]
Damn! Okay, okay.
I get it --
you guys don't like bracelets.
And that's why we will each have
a small sticker
on the back of our --
[ Crowd booing ]
God damn! I really thought
the sticker would work.
Okay. Okay.
How about we wear
"Black Lives Matter" T-shirts --
[ Crowd booing ]
Well, hear me out first.
Dang! Okay?
So, the "Black Lives Matters"
T-shirts,
but it will be
under our jerseys,
so you won't be able
to see them,
but we will know that we --
[ Crowd booing ]
You didn't even see them!
But, okay. How about
"Black Lives Matter" --
[ Crowd booing ]
You didn't even let me finish.
"Black Lives" --
[ Crowd booing ]
Hold on.
Let me see something.
Black...
[ Crowd booing ]
How are you guys gonna boo
any time anything "Black"?
[ Crowd booing ]
And you guys sure you didn't
like the bracelet idea?
-No!
-Well, that's --
that's unfortunate.
My wife -- My wife was really
excited about making them.
Anyways, instead of a knee
or a T-shirt,
we'll just stand in protest
against racism.
[ Crowd boos ]
Wh-- What?!
At this point,
what do you guys want us to do?!
We'll just do nothing,
but we'll know and you'll know
it's a stance against racism.
[ Crowd boos ]
Wait.
Are you guys pro-racism?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh. That makes sense.
Some of y'all are racist.